Alain de Botton hello hello such a
pleasure
Wow I have been a fan for over 20 years
that's amazing it ages us both but in a
good way and for the noblest of reasons
so what a pleasure for me yeah I I grew
up in Venezuela so I was reading the art
of travel in the bathtub in like 1997 I
remember and the the words were
resonating so profoundly even back then
as a 16 year old you know I just so I
just I want to salute you for the
amazing impact that you have on people
around the world with your just
astounding reflections on the human
condition thank you thank you wow that's
so kind we'll end it we'll end it there
right that's it thank you so much nice
to see if I how are you good yeah yeah
you know life is always it's never
stable very nervous there is never a
stable destination there's always stuff
coming in there's always anxiety
incompleteness desire yeah but that's
okay I mean it's okay you know I've
learned to accept that I've learned to
accept that there is no destination so
you are able to live with equanimity and
grace in spite of the constant
incompleteness of the human condition
and even when there is no equanimity and
no grace I know it will return I mean
you know I don't want to set myself
armed some people say things like oh wow
you know I've read your stuff and you
must be incredibly calm and wise I'm
like no no no no no no you know if you
see me at the airport like kicking my
own suitcases and collapsing in tears
yeah that's me you know and I want to
own that the demented guy because I
think that our madness is is part of us
and I think to aspire to superior wisdom
has to be compatible with checking in on
an almost daily and hourly basis with
one's insanity once idiocy wants
childlike nature and the notion of the
guru who is somehow always poised you
know always appropriate is wrong I've
always been frightened of these people I
have an
allergy to gurus for the very same
reason so the self-righteousness feels
like a like a total scam you know like
like they're they're not really showing
themselves because to show themselves
would be to show me their suffering
their insecurities their self-doubt
their fatalism you know I mean you see
on the other the other day the Pope was
quote slapping one of his well wishes
and you know this is a major moment in
civilizing absolutely because there is
the Pope caught on camera doing
something which is a one level very
human yes and and the other level not at
all people that's right and so that sets
up you know this dichotomy between you
know what do we think that someone can
be and should be if they're living
according to Christ and actually what
they are and I think you could live
according to Christ and lose your temper
and and that's okay yeah so I think you
know what my favorite philosophers
Montaigne this was his big thing what
makes that philosopher so interesting is
he's he's fascinated by our ordinary
humanity you know he's the first
philosopher to talk about farting and
[ __ ] and sexual desire and appetites
for radishes and carrots and you know
the woman he's seen you know in the next
castle and all the rest of it this is a
sensory you know there's a wonderful
quote he goes Kings and philosophers
[ __ ] and so do ladies oh well you know
and on there I have to pull up a quote
for you yeah because this this reality
of the human condition the sort of the
sacred and the profane yeah right or or
you know Ernest Becker in the denial of
death which is a book that also
resonated with me profoundly talks about
how us being gods with anuses we are
simultaneously gods and worms show and
since we're off to the races and already
talking about [ __ ] there's a quote
that he wrote that I wanted yeah yeah he
says that excreting which is another
word for taking a dump is the curse that
threatens madness because it shows man
his abject finitude his physicalness the
likely unreality of his hopes and dreams
but even
more immediately defecation represents
man's utter bafflement at the sheer
nonsense of creation to fashion the
sublime miracle of the human face the
mysterium tremendum of radiant feminine
beauty the veritable goddesses that
beautiful women are to bring this all
out of nothing out of the void and make
it shine in noonday to take such a
miracle and put miracles again within it
deep in the mystery of eyes that peer
out the eye that gave even the dry
Darwin a chill to do all of this and to
combine it with an anus that shits it is
too much nature mocks us and the poets
live in torture you just have this on
your phone you whip it out it no I mean
it's it's beautiful and you were that
bit in Milan Kundera's Unbearable
Lightness of being well he's the the
narrator the hero gets together with
this woman and in the middle of
lovemaking she needs to go to the
bathroom [ __ ] and and and actually it's
a very moving thing because he says you
know if you love somebody you're gonna
love them for that you're gonna love
them for their humanity because that's
where the humanity is located and I
think well know that we'll talk about
love but one of the things about love is
accepting somebody in you know a range
of Moo's and a range of registers sure
which is going to include go into the
bathroom and and still loving them you
know not just tolerating but loving them
so so that's something that we humans
are not so good at I mean for thousands
of years we've not had a very good
relationship with our bodies right we
absolutely are self divided creatures
half the population is still you know
unable to deal with certain basic facts
about them they're their own desires
their own needs physical needs etc and I
think that you know whenever Kingsley
Amos said that his sex drive was like
being chained to an idiot and and there
is something that we are all chained to
idiots but but not just a one idiot and
we were probably chained to a dozen
idiots of all different kinds we've got
these competing priorities so to be a
thinking person to have intellectual
ambitions is always to be only a few
millimeters away from rid the ridiculous
because we are being tugged in all sorts
of other directions you know this is
I have always found confounding about
the human condition because I'm so
aesthetically oriented I am attracted to
things that resonate with my Sensibility
I'm interested as I think you are in
many ways in in truth in beauty and with
the French called free zone you know the
skin orgasm I like experiences that make
the hairs on the back of my neck stand
up I'm chasing radiance and all and you
know III think you've summed it better
than anyone when you said you know we
don't cry when something is sad we cry
when something is more beautiful than we
expected it to be and and Dawkins
recently said I don't cry when I'm sad I
cry when I'm moved yeah and I think it
was Pico Iyer who said we don't travel
to move around we travel in order to be
moved so there's a there's this human
sort of orientation around the sublime
and the things that make us well up that
move us to tear that move us beyond our
animality but but there's a very big you
know like the the defecation the the
animal the entropy the gravity the death
the mortality it's like and also the
sadness I mean the thing about beauty is
that it's a well known thing that people
will start to cry more as they get older
at certain simple but beautiful things
so you know if you show an
eleven-year-old oh no it's so not an 11
or a 5 year old I used to have a 5 year
old it's now grown but when I had a 5
year when out of 5 year old I would you
know come back from a day in the city
you know fighting among other humans and
there were competing needs etc and I'd
come to his bedroom and it was quiet and
the light was dim and he was angelic and
you know we pick up a book about a
little penguin looking for its mother
you know among the ice floes of of
Antarctica yeah and after a few page
with this I would be in tears and I had
to hide these tears from him because he
think you know my father's a madman but
the reason why it was so beautiful is
that the emotions on the page were
describing such simple book
of loyalty and tenderness and kindness
all these things which an adult life are
under such stress in such short supply
meaning they are our true home and so
when you see your true home in a
children's book or you know in a
beautiful location etc you want to go
that's it that's home but but it's
disappearing it's it's a mirage or it's
it's you know it's and the older you get
the more you realize that you know those
little islands of beauty and truth and
kindness and justice they're only ever
gonna be islands you can't take
permanent residence there and and that's
why when you see something beautiful you
get that simultaneous experience of both
pleasure and sadness and melancholy I
mean the Japanese are so keen on this
this whole Japanese aesthetics is based
around the melancholy you feel at
knowing that something beautiful is only
transient including our own what this I
mean this gets to the heart of my entire
life I mean that's why I resonate so so
deeply with you I'm a big fan of the
director Cameron Crowe yeah
Dino Cameron Rosso so he has this term
that he use is called the happy sad and
the happy sad is the reason why he
deploys usually just goosebump inducing
melancholy in his movies through his
song choices through the way a character
might interact with another character
with just a simple glance and he often
said making a movie is just an excuse to
get into the editing room and set it to
music you know and I learned this phrase
happy-sad it speaks too much to me when
I was you know 12 years old 13 years old
I used to film family events I already
had a video camera to film family event
and then I would edit them with my dual
deck vcr dub it from one to the other
and then i would add like the saddest
possible song that i could find you know
i would find like Moon River from
Breakfast at Tiffany's or the auld lang
syne because I already was attuned to
the feeling of sort of the the
melancholic and like wistful longing of
the passing moment and what once was and
is no longer and it just gripped me you
know and it very quickly led me to an
emotional release or a cathartic release
yeah but it doesn't mean that I was at
peace with the moment
but I had at least grieved through it
you know enough to move on with my with
my day but you know you say that people
start to get more sad at beautiful
simple things when they get older you
know I've been like that since I was
like right there you're advanced no but
of course I mean think of flowers right
like no I mean maybe you but but very
few 11-year olds are enchanted by
flowers but there are very few seventy
year olds who are not enchanted by
flowers like every 70 year-old I've ever
met yeah it's like keen on gardening now
why is that it's because this symbol of
you know beauty in a perfect you know
miniature form and this this evidence of
new life and and the modesty of the kind
of the yeah the beauty that a flower per
tokens all of this is profoundly
touching when your own mortality is very
much in insight and you know if you
think of Islamic pottery or Chinese
porcelain ware you know these guys which
is painting beautiful little flowers
again and again and again and think of
the fear of death these are also violent
regimes life was tough oh yeah life was
difficult but what did they want to put
on a table just a beautiful finely
crafted thing with lots of you know line
of little flowers on it and and I loved
the I love the the gravity and the
seriousness I mean van Gogh just shortly
before he took his life attempted to
take his life you know he was painting
flowers again and again and again yeah
what was it about these flowers that was
drawing him at those darkest most
troubled moments when people say oh I
like flowers you think Oh sentimental
you know must have had a cheerful life
and never known suffering at all you
know it's those who suffer most who I
think are alive
most of those little islands but you
know it could be a flower getting lost
and it could be Lawrence you talk about
museums as should be like secular
temples or like secular churches and I
think it was it was the architecture of
happiness that you first started to get
into this like we can design spaces that
the power of art and architecture to to
move us you know that is those of us
that are most may be acquainted with
pain that are then more
sensitive to certain works of beauty and
certain works of art certain buildings
that can just like immediately move us
to tears totally totally and if I can
just sidetrack yeah back to the museum's
in a minute but yeah sidetracked to love
on this yeah I mean if two lovers meet
for the first time and one of them says
you know hey my life's great and I'm
really I'm really kind of advancing
towards new peaks of satisfaction and
accomplishment but that is a really hard
person to feel close to but if somebody
says you know despite you know my active
life it cetera off tonight I feel broken
I feel sad I feel I feel that I'm lost
you know wow this is somebody you can
love and can let yourself be loved by so
you know behind intimacy there is the
revelation of of brokenness I mean it's
that why I'm always attracted to the
wounded feminine we all are well I think
we should be well first of all people
like this we are all wounded I mean
Christianity and Buddhism saw this way
ahead of time you know for Christianity
and indeed Judah Judaism we are all the
inheritors of the sins of Adam and Eve
we are all original sinners now you
could go whoa oh that's serious and
that's horrible that's punitive and it
does have that quality
however looked at another way what that
really means is all of us are imperfect
we are all fundamentally imperfect not
because of this or that thing we've done
wrong but simply by being human we are
imperfect creatures of longing and error
and mistakes this is endemic to our
nature now once we recognize that and
accept it with good grace and you this
crops up in Buddhism - you know Buddhism
says its verse 10 it is life is
suffering in other words we are
creatures that suffer now once we accept
our broken suffering nature and put that
on the table on an early dating scenario
that's a real relief and indeed in all
interactions I mean all friendship all
genuine friendship begins the moment we
take down the mask and we go I'm
suffering this is difficult for me every
time that you'd trade with somebody a
piece of information that puts you in a
vulnerable position and departs from the
script that we're all given about what a
successful life is that's friendship
we're still not very good at friendship
with it happens by accident it's like
stumbling on a city square late at night
you go oh how did I get there in the
morning you
can't find it again but systematically
this is what we should do
that's our friendship begins and that's
how love begins a 300% it reminds me of
that um Timothy Leary quote but find the
others and he says that you know most of
us rely on Club passwords like how you
doing good how you doing good that's a
real one figure in America what we
really longed to say things like what
are you afraid of
how are you broken you know what makes
you cry
how are you mad yeah how are you crazy
how are you what do you what are you
afraid of at 3:00 a.m. that's right and
I said generally that's a really big
thing you know and and you know we do a
thing at the School of Life which where
we gather when we have like a big event
yeah well gather people sometimes it to
break the ice will say to people look
turn to a stranger and left or right and
say to them something you regret
something you're ashamed of and
something you're afraid of just turn to
them and do that with them I love this
exercise and it works unfailingly that
just by those simple commands from the
stage it transforms the atmosphere in a
room yeah and you could be doing it with
a group of CEOs who completely guarded
their you know they've swallowed the
American success story
but suddenly something another door
opens and it's a beautiful thing to see
and it's you know it's such an irony we
we spend so much of our energy trying to
impress others when really what we need
is a sense of communion with others
which is not based on impressing them to
impress another person is also to shut
them off it's to close off our humanity
from theirs and so our our success
oriented culture is fundamentally
unlinked with our emotional aspirations
to connect with other humans you are
such a beautiful speaker you are I love
hearing you go on you know there's
there's a bunch of oh it's actually you
know phrases from from several of your
books that have resonated for years you
know something else I'm interested in is
is human truth and and the importance of
finding some distinction between
objective
and how you call it poetic truth you
know or bruno latour talks about modes
of existence
you know Chronos and Kairos in terms of
the Greeks different ways of
interpreting reality interpreting time
there's like mechanized cognition
reality by the clock and then there's
like subjective poetic reality the
truthful fictions in which we live and
so on and so forth and I remember this
one line that you said that uh something
to the degree of a journalist may be
more accurate in describing the details
of an event than a poet but a poet may
nevertheless reveal truths of a deeper
sort that are beyond the literal grid
sure I mean you know this is the what is
this space beyond the literal grid was
that a real space yes I mean you know
think of when Picasso was he painted
Gertrude Stein in in a fractured cubist
way and people said it doesn't look like
Gertrude Stein and he famously answered
it will and and in other words that he
was seeing well that he was seeing
something in her that later would become
clear or Francis Bacon said as well you
know when you're painting somebody it's
often the dis the so called distorted
element will get closer to the truth
than the literal truth and it's in that
way that you know as as we were saying
you know the poet might go ahead of the
journalist in right in in grasping
something important you know it comes to
us something we were just talking about
it before we went on Arab about academia
yeah you know academia is wedded to a
rather naive scientific model or you
know the truth and so when academics
tackling subjects they'll tend to
proceed in you know as if there is a way
of being utterly faithful to a
phenomenon not realizing that a poet
might rush ahead of them and and and get
you know get there in three stanzas yeah
where they've been laboring for years
with a certain kind of approach and so
do you think that obviously we need both
right we need a kind of objective
compliant consensus reality but we also
need the real
personal experience because we get so
much nourishment from that that's the
mythopoetic that's the liminal that's
the dream like that's the meaning making
spaces of humans but do you think when
we blur the lines that divide those
domains is when we get into trouble so
it's like when people have an interior
experience that's true for them but they
want it to be true for everybody else it
turns it turns poetic truth into
Scripture and into guru hood and into
like a post truth world where you know
opinions are like [ __ ] and everybody
has one but they're claiming their
opinion is the truth you know so how do
we make sure that we keep that line
intent because obviously you know I I
hosted a TV show National Geographic
called brain games all about the
objective reality of how the brain works
miss that but like so much of the stuff
that I explored my videos and in my art
I'm interested in the ineffable interior
landscapes you know I'm I'm interested
in like well you wrote about it in the
art of travels is those moments where
how pleasant to hold in mind through the
crevices of our modes at 3:00 in the
afternoon when lassitude and despair
threatened that there is always an
airplane taking off or somewhere
Baudelaires like what is that what does
that have to do with objective reality
but that's the feeling I resonate I
connect with it's true for me yeah
obviously true for you yeah I mean look
it's all context appropriate in context
specific I mean I had an example of this
the other day I was just flying back
from Abu Dhabi on Etihad Airways Etihad
Airways is owned by oh yeah one of the
major effects on the resident was
amazing shakes no I didn't I didn't fly
in the residence but you know I was
surprised that shortly before takeoff
we had an Arabic prayer and and I
thought you know let's not pray this
thing gets off the ground let's pray
that we get to our destination let's do
some sums let the guys at Airbus and the
well-trained pilots
yes life science and reason to get this
bird over to London yes and then prayer
has another place and and I think that
you know the two you know should exist
in separate realms church and state
church and state that's exactly how I
feel about it you know Ursula Le Guin
has a great line also in this as you can
tell this is a subject that has captured
my mind but she says science describes
accurately from the outside poetry
describes accurately from the inside
science Expo
kate's poetry implicates both celebrate
what they describe I mean that's like
spot on I mean your example of the
airplane is is 100% I fly a lot and I
and then like you I I marvel at these
birds you know that there's that passage
from the art of travel when you talk
about what like Leonardo and I have
thought if he flew in a modern plane and
then he looked at the window and he said
we're fighting we're flying through a
cloud you know like and then most people
just close the shutter and complain that
so it's like yeah you want mathematics
you want like all these equations and
these engineers that worked for 30 years
mechanical and just to design that these
reliable machines you don't want to pray
that the airplane takes off but then
again you know I was in an observatory
in in Spain in the Canary Islands a
little while ago and you know the the I
was with the tour guide and they were
spending a lot of time trying to explain
the difference between this galaxies in
this constellation and this dad and the
other and I was thinking look you know
what I'm here I just want the general
picture I don't need to know you know
that it's Kepler 34b or Kepler 33 EB I
don't that doesn't I am NOT an
astronomer and therefore my interest in
this is humanistic yes and poetic and
not scientific and I think that
sometimes you know those who were in
charge of the sciences who are building
science museums Natural History Museum's
you know places because you know they
forget as the average person is
interested in its you know in a poetic
sense not in a scientific they don't
need to know every last detail they want
to know you know when the Stoics Stoics
were some of the what I love about the
Stoics of ancient Rome is that it was
spectacularly bad at studying the Stars
like they made various studies and they
got it all wrong however they almost
admitted that their real interest lay
not in discovering the nature of the
stars in the universe but in using the
spectacle of the universe to bring calm
to their souls and so from that point of
view they succeeded yeah and but I think
the West has has become a little bit
confused about what its priorities are
and I think that most of us who are
outside a scientific community do you
need science but we need to look at it
in the way that we
normally operate which is through a
humanistic lens so what do we need to
know from the stars we need to know that
we're very very small do we need to know
for that every last detail no we don't
we just need to be awed in a proper way
we don't need to know every last detail
and when we look at you know Natural
History Museum's and we see you know
this bone came from this area or Siberia
it said you know after a certain point
it often these guys are laboring us with
details that we don't need because the
message is general rather than specific
in their work they need to know the
details for sure we don't need to know
that so I think so so both are necessary
and it just depends on the audience you
know it's like if you think of the film
contact with Jodie Foster you know she's
this wonderful scientist but she's also
a wonder junkie and all the science and
they get the message from the aliens and
they build a ship and it's you know it's
beautiful it's sublime it's mathematics
it's oh my god the truth of science and
it builds the wormhole and she goes to
the other end of the witnesses a
celestial event and then what does she
say they should have sent a poet
yeah they should have sent a poet you
know there's this marvelous article
written by a guy called Ross Anderson I
don't know if I sent it to you it's
called Goldeneye and it's about the
Hubble Space Telescope and the images
that it took of the of the Deep Field
and you know he what I loved about that
piece is he talked about the
metaphysical and philosophical power the
philosophical wonderment evoked by the
Deep Field images so even though those
images were taken by a sublime
instrument of science everything about
the Hubble is science but then what does
the Hubble do it mainlines
space and time through the optic nerve
right through the sheer aesthetic force
of its discoveries the esthetic force of
its discoveries the Hubble distills the
complex abstractions of astrophysics
into singular expressions of color and
light vindicating Keats famous couplet
beauty is truth truth is beauty there
you go that's right that's beautiful and
and you know part of the problem is that
we because we because this distinction
is not alive in our minds we miss out on
a whole range of aesthetic experiences
for example flight because when people
go in an aeroplane yes they are not
prepared to have an aesthetic experience
because they have been
all that they are going through
scientific you know journey to another
land and that's it and and then you know
artists you know bless them are kind of
trying to catch up and trying sometimes
in the narrower space of the museum yeah
trying to sometimes recapture some of
those feelings but yeah we need to be
ready to see the aesthetic in areas
where we think it's merely material in
scientific yes and and I think for that
to happen we have to pierce our
representations right because as we go
as we grow from children to adults we
start to create these maps of how the
world works in our brain and then we
rely on those maps and for the most part
that serves us well so we can commute to
work and so on and so forth but
eventually we forget that the map is not
the territory and the territory is far
more interesting and has so much more to
it than just the utilitarian function of
those maps and so how do we do that you
know Michael sorry to interrupt you
Michael Pollan who wrote this new book
about psychedelic psychotherapy he has
this great passage he was writing about
cannabis the marijuana the texture of
the subjective experience of cannabis
and he says that what it does is it
evokes a sense of first sight
unencumbered by knowingness so the
knowingness or the jaded miss or the the
I don't I know what that is
dismisses what's there and leapfrogs to
the conclusion it goes straight to the
concept but occasionally that virginal
noticing of the sensei or that sense a
first sight unencumbered by knowing this
is it well it catalyzes oh and wonder
you need to forget what you know in
order to see the world in a grain of
sand and heaven in a wild flower and so
on yes and it's you know it's the
paradox that if we were constantly
amazed and our senses were constantly
alive we couldn't get through the day
yes so the capacity to be habituated to
be unaware yes is a survival strategy
and at the same time it's a killing
strategy that's right so we have to we
have to get it right and that's why you
know so many of those moments when we
step outside the known of our daily
lives and it could be I mean a favorite
thing is being awake at an odd time of
day or night so you know if you wake up
at 3 a.m. and you go to the kitchen
right and you look at the kitchen
wow how weird the kitchen is there's
this thing called the fridge
what's it doing sir there's a bowl of
fruit on the sideboard what is that what
is a banana at 3:00 in the morning a
banana is like a spectral event I mean
it's crazy that's right
being ill you know when you're
recovering from an illness let's imagine
that you know your your sinuses have
been getting lost you've been laboring
under a fever a few days and then that
mood is is lifting and and suddenly
you're back into the work and it's like
being born again hundred percent so so
there are and you know drugs are another
version but for me drugs are only one of
a category of for sure you know motions
and and potions that you can take yeah
in order to to break the spell of habit
ya know no doubt he he he says what is
banality and boredom who's he sorry um
Michael Pollan also I think this is
exactly what you said he says what is
banality and boredom except techniques
that the educated mind deploys against
experience so that it can get through
the day without being continually
exhaustingly astonished right and so
that's fine for maybe like I call it
like default world like fetching water
and chopping wood but we must make room
for the ritual aesthetic and mythopoetic
domains like we need to make the magic
circle and we need to carve that as
something that we need a couple times a
week the same way we need food a couple
times a day that's right that's right
there's a recognize that about yourself
and yes for Proust who I spend a lot of
time reading and thinking about that the
thing that does that first and foremost
is art yes now I think that's too much
of a kind of classic 19th century French
way of looking at things I think the
realm of art is perhaps larger it's not
just a painting that you see of course
great works of art do do this but but as
I say it can also be you know falling in
love recovery from an illness insomnia
you know taking an aeroplane traveling
of all kinds I mean you know why do we
like to travel we like to travel because
you're forced when traveling to break
through the veil of habit and to see you
know once a new that kind of wonder of
the world that you know that is dull
I mean and people have always I have
often said that like falling in love
becomes a deliberate act of
aestheticizing
reality yes like I am deliberately
raising this to an aesthetic domain
people call it well you shouldn't
idealize people and like no actually
it's the opposite you know what's
delightful about falling in love is the
idea in the sort of ideal izing the
entire rhapsodic stage play that you're
creating like let's go here together
let's go to that restaurant that's
decorated in that way let's listen to
this song together let's run through the
forest together like you know let's
create an enchanted realm together
Ernest Becker call it a cosmology of two
right I mean the people who do this
always in very naturally over many years
are parents of their children I mean
parents are continuously in love with
their children yes and you know they'll
go oh my god you know the kid drew a
picture of us the skull and they like oh
wow that's amazing or not that amazing
thing the kid ate an egg or whatever and
they are permanently in love yeah but we
also have this from adult love I mean
there's that wonderful feeling when you
first fall in love with somebody and I
don't think they take you home and you
know they open the front door and
suddenly it's their home and it's like
wow that their shoes and like oh and
they've got some books older stuff and
then they show you that bathroom and
it's like really that's your soap there
were and it's their world their photos
on their fridge of their life you know
you've had such a poetical yeah I think
your life so no one view is to say
that's idealized that's a myth and
that's gonna disappear within three
weeks however we could flip it around
and go know that a truth that's the
truth that is how God looks in it we
don't believe in God I don't even got
but you know if we were holy men if we
were holy men that is what God would see
that's a holiness and preciousness of
every single human that ever little
doubt but outside of a lover in the
first three weeks or a parent we don't
normally get that but we should and and
it's it's almost you know we need to be
jogged into that and I think that's what
people have always looked to to drugs to
religion to art technologies of ecstasy
technology you you're faster than me no
no no because no because you've you've
charted this territory so well I think
it's I'm interested in the deliberate
hacking of our subjectivity right
there's a guy called Eric Davis he wrote
a book called tech gnosis myth magic and
mysticism in the age of information
you would love him he's been on the
podcast I'll send you the episode but he
talks about experience design and now
we're living of course in the experience
economy cuz now every whole idea is like
as advances in psychology which you know
a lot about technology neurobiology and
also pharmacology are all advancing so
it's giving us this capacity to steward
the contents of lived experience in a
way we never have before
so we're talking about directly engaging
the technical material of subjectivity
itself that means designer ecstatic
radiance designer aesthetic ecstasy but
but even the idea of having some kind of
agency over this experience has governed
my life like that's like kind of what I
want it doesn't mean I need to feel that
way all the time
because I agree with you we get depleted
we get it but I don't want to feel like
it's this half hazard thing that once in
a while the light shines through the
trees and I can get some of that grace
but I want that grace to be something I
can get in a reproducible manner of
course once in a while the people that's
beautiful the people who thought hardest
about designing this for millions of
people were of course religions yes I
mean religions are structured routes to
feelings of exit II transcendence
community etc the new middle and and
when we did away with religion apart
from just doing away with certain ideas
about how the world was formed and what
would happen to us after we died we lost
touch with all of this stuff that's
right and I know you're interested in
this I'm very interested in this but you
know we are living properly in a post
religious age and what does that really
mean and I think we need to make sure
that our lives have got a lot of what
religious lives used to have outside of
the you know the supernatural bit but
very much around tron particularly
around transcendence and community or in
other words we need regular reminders of
everything that exceeds us in in an
ecstatic way rather than a dispiriting
way that is one of the terrible things
is that when we come into full awareness
of the smallness of our egos and the
insignificance alive this is normally
experienced in modern individualistic
society as a
despair that's right and that's crazy we
need to flip that right answer this
should be seen as the beginning of
something beautiful of course
our insignificance rather than be
something we could go limps out of the
corner of our eye the fact we are
insignificant can be redeemed if it's
set within a broader context no doubt
you know that the narrative and the
interpretive framework matters you know
I mean Carl Sagan said you know for
small creatures such as we the vastness
is bearable only through love you know
like that's kind of beautiful he also
said we are way for the cosmos to know
itself which is a bit more empowering
young Neil deGrasse Tyson goes even
further and he says look when I say how
big the universe is and I see myself but
I know that the atoms in my bodies were
cooked in the furnaces of stars and the
atoms in my right in my left arm were
probably cooked in the different in the
different furnace of a different star
than the atoms in my right hand so when
I see the universe I don't feel small I
feel big so it also how do we interpret
a narrative that serves us yeah and also
that might in a certain mood enable us
to greet our own death
with less than horror yeah we would
almost be able to surrender back to you
know celestial space from whence we came
with a certain grace because we think
I'm going home rather than my ego is
dissolving and I mean you know this was
always the Buddhist way yeah rather than
trying to say you know the egos
dissolution is a tragedy it is actually
the beginning of a kind of return to
truth which is that we were always
belonged to the universe and we're just
returning that it's been very very hard
I mean there's a part of our brains they
really resist that oh yeah but our
brains are complicated machines and we
can without deluding ourselves yeah I
think talk ourselves into greater
acceptance for the inevitability and
it's very interesting because this what
you're saying is exactly the one of the
incidental effects of people who have
high-dose psychedelic experiences in
guided settings they have a mystical
experience and William James the
psychologist he had all this criteria
there's that if you met all this all
these all these things you know
transcendence of time and space a sense
of the noetic deeper poetic truth beyond
the literal grid a sense of like
ravishing well-being and then you had
these experiences and Method Carter for
a mystical earth and people who have a
mystical experience who up until that
point maybe we're
from treatment resistant depression
anxiety PTSD OCD which by the way all of
them have are the same in the brain it's
over rumination and excessive
self-consciousness it's an ego whose
patterns of thinking have calcified and
so you're stuck in like negatively
reinforced patterns of thought and that
these psychedelic mystical experiences
shake the snow globe yeah effectively
and so those grooves get resolved and
then people feel a direct encounter with
other with the other with the grande
other and when they come out and for
years afterwards they're no longer
afraid of death but I think in order to
do that we need a road map I mean you
can't just put somebody in the edge of
the Grand Canyon and say get on with it
no we need I mean religion is doing that
there were these things called rituals
integration so you you have to kind of
create the experience I mean I always
think that humans are very easily
suggestible in other words our behavior
is very guided by what we meant to think
and feel at any point in any given
context think of an art gallery when you
walk into an art gallery it just says
you know art gallery above the door and
suddenly you behave like in an art
gallery you go silent you put your arms
next to you and you look with great
intent at things on the wall if somebody
said she's not an art gallery this is
actually you know I don't know a public
space of some kind a railway station
people change a few changes
so we are our behaviors so context
dependent yeah or easily mediated yeah
but that's a good thing that's a good
thing except that unfortunately there
are not very many interesting goals at
the moment out there in society I mean
if you said look I'm looking for a
transcendental experience you know I've
come to your country and I'm looking for
time so it was like what this is not
available here we have a water park we
have a safari but we we don't know what
you mean
so we don't even know that language I
mean think of the average five-star
hotel right the world is dotted with
five-star hotels they are supposed to be
the peak of civilizations attempt to
create happiness in another human sir
you show up at a five-star hotel and you
go right so I'm looking for deeper forms
of happiness connection meaning etc I
mean you would be shown out of the
building they don't know what that means
yeah so and that's indicative not of a
problem you know in in hostel
but it's a problem in modern
materialistic society we don't have our
higher psychological needs sufficiently
in view we don't have a language in
which talk about them you know if you
went to a museum and you said I'm here
to you know reconnect with my soul and I
can figure my vision you would be thrown
out yeah if you went to the Oxford or
Cambridge philosophy department and you
said you know I'm here to discover you
know The Ecstatic in the new middle and
my soul and it also ludia so that's
telling us something yeah it's telling
us that in many many contexts things
that are eminently reasonable and found
a place for thousands of years within
the organized structures of religions
are now deemed close to insanity so no
wonder we have a problem with mental
what we call mental health yeah cuz
because an orphan no spaces yeah no
spaces so a lot of people are being
shunted into that space called you're
ill you know it's so interesting to hear
you say that because I I just hear
myself like I've always said it's like I
wish that I could rent a Gothic
cathedral and stage design my own like
now static okay I don't want to play
Hans Zimmer music and require everybody
to take three hits of a strong THC joint
before they walk in you know to make
themselves more porous more suggestible
and have an ecstatic Jason yes as you
say this beautiful idea there's a
slightly ironic smirk on your lips
yeah no smoke smiling yeah as though
this was a crazy idea this is a very
sane idea yeah this needs to happen yeah
and I think that one of the things
that's happened is that people who know
how to organize stuff who know how to
build cathedrals organize large numbers
of people deal with money they're all in
one camp and they tend to have a rather
flattened view of life and those who
dream and those who have the visions
yeah are reduced to podcasting yeah and
making little filters and like me
writing book and putting myself in this
category right yeah we don't have the
practical confidence to reach out to
these guys and to create what I think
religions always did yeah which was to
marry up the you know material and
procedural and bureaucratic side of life
yeah with spiritual ambition and I think
that my hope for the 21st century is
that we're gonna go and do more of that
so that you will start your Cathedral
and I want to go there yeah
yeah well you've written up manuals
architecture happiness the art of travel
unloved the consolations of philosophy
out browse literally since over 20 years
I know but look should I tell you my you
know we're the beginning of 2020 shall I
tell you my ambitions now for the rest
of my life yes okay so my ambition so I
started the School of Life there but
what I really really want to do is I
want to start a community I want to
start a kind of I'm really interested in
monasticism monasticism sits on top of
Epicureanism Epicureanism was the first
attempt in greco-roman society to bring
people together around shared values
community love kindness the pursuit of
truth they built you know society a
little miniature society where you would
retreat from the big city and you'd live
among friends committed to these goals
yeah I remember reading this when I was
25 thinking this is not possible these
guys were writing about this and this is
a dream you know the guy who did his PhD
thesis on Epicurus was Karl Marx
communism is a state-run authoritarian
and rather dispiriting version of
epicureanism there is a much more
charming but anyway the reason I'm
telling you this is yeah it would be
fantastic to start a network of
communities dedicated to some of the
stuff we've been talking about where you
wouldn't just check in every now and
then on a youtube film you wouldn't just
you know come and you would actually
shape your life that way you know you
say you we were talking about your
nomadic lifestyle yeah right many of us
you know what are our options in the
modern world we're given an option of
two things a standard career and a you
know family with 2.2 children in the
suburbs right that is what it means to
be normal and for many of us it doesn't
quite work we want to hang out in a
network of friends we want to have our
lives guided by certain values etcetera
where do we go how do we do this and you
be sort of digital native and you live
around the world I know and that's very
very hard for most people yeah yeah so
so you know the thing the thing that
frustrates me about tech is I'm sure it
frustrates you these guys are all the
time bringing inventiveness to bear on
pretty small problems or pretty banal
problems you know it's like yes it's
good to be able to get a map to order
you at Fried Chicken in the middle of
the night great fantastic we'll measure
your pulse etre but they're really big
challenges and the really big things
that that dragged our lives down are
around disconnection
to being cut off from the transcendent
cut off from meaning etc that's right
now
imagine if we were trying to hack some
way a ways into setting up big solutions
to these problems and we brought the
engines of capitalism and the engines
and the disciplines of bureaucracy and
commerce to bear on these things if we
built a network of temples that replaced
the religious structures of old and
replaces the way we would go in order to
look at the Stars yeah and get in touch
with our own smallness in a structured
and beautiful way what if we were able
to employ artists the great artists you
know who used to work in the service of
religion and now tend to work merely in
the service of their own egos and if we
harness them and their creative powers
to a bigger mission and we get when to
the musicians yeah and we said instead
of Jim merely talking about those early
moments of love if you took your you
know musical genius and made that in the
service of the transcendent and a
luminal and ultimate meaning and created
something to rival you know Bach's mass
in B minor then again we would be
getting somewhere to a new stage so my
goal is goosebumps right so my goal is
can we try and move from you know you
and I we know the theory can we advance
over the coming decade into the practice
have you been to Burning Man I haven't
been very interested in it and it took
me a long time before I went did you
like it now I've been twice you know I
think that that a lot of the the
difficulty in getting there and in
getting comfortable yeah is makes it
very self-selecting yeah
pilgrimage in it and it's hard and even
once you're there sometimes it's hard
with the dust and the heat and this and
that but there are some moments you know
at sunset or sunrise you have to realize
the art is built for ecstatic encounters
okay and it's a juxtaposition of just
insane or just why are we talking only
about one Burning Man sure sure but not
thousand people healed acidity for a
week for that experience it's fantastic
yeah and good good for there yeah but we
need more of this yes and in a way when
people always talk to me about any
manners like that's the only thing that
planets manage to do right in this area
we need something for the guys who can't
leave their families and their jobs for
you know weeks to go on a pleasure but
who are able to do this just on a
Thursday night you know among their
friends and and that kind of thing so
we need so much inventiveness around
ritualizing and structuring the kind of
spiritual psychological dimension of you
have life just at the beginning of
working out what to do and and I think
I've always been struck by the divide
between the artists who you know has the
vision but can't hold a pen can't you
know do anything practical in life and
and the practical people who are
terrifically practical but is so neutral
about the ends to which their practical
skills not put yeah and you know I have
people in business and they're like I'm
like do you want to change the world and
they go no no I just you don't want to
make some money and you want to go
really that's the trip I don't know it's
such a peculiar end given that life is
so finite you know so so we want to try
and connect those there here it's so
interesting because you know that's what
that's what religion sort of used to be
them and that's church that's the mosque
it's the temple I mean that the
buildings speak to that intention still
and you know I'm not sure if there was a
time when cinema maybe art house cinemas
also were about that you know when I I
loved cinema so when I go to the movie
movies III am in a reverential state
already like I am ready to sit in the
dark and see the light literally I am
ready to experience truth twenty four
times per second I am literally I'm
ready to experience art as the lie that
reveals the truth and but what has
happened you know now with the criticism
of Marvel films they're like
entertainment theme parks instead of
like art it's what some people are
saying is that you go to the movie
theater and it's like all you see now is
coca-cola commercials popcorn and kids
making noise and like thirty minutes of
commercials before the movie starts I
know so then the movie is not as good as
it should be and the reason is not that
people are more stupid than they ever
were but that we haven't set the
priorities what is cinema for exactly we
we haven't really properly you know it's
still a kind of form of luck like oh
that was a good film but that was about
them we don't we don't even know why I
mean I think you ought to start with the
subject matter you know what are we
doing what are we trying to get these
films to do to us oh I will tell you
exactly Jeanne Youngblood wrote a book
called expanded cinema in the 70s and he
said cinema reflects mankind's
historical drive to
manifest his consciousness outside of
his mind in front of his eyes okay so
when we watch a film
we're meeting what consciousness meets
its own process so this should be
written on the Hollywood Hills oh no no
the sign no doubt and when these guys
you know show up or show up to work it's
like what are we doing what are we
looking for the next hit no no you're
looking to mirror conscious mirror
consciousness that's what you do so when
you're making a film about a married
couple you're trying to mirror the
consciousness of marriage know down when
you're trying to make a film about
gangsters you mirror you know etc etc
and also because you know even you think
of what you when you stare at a screen
you're not staring at a screen you're
staring into a screen a close-up of a
gifted actor you're not seeing their
face up close you're looking into their
soul right so at its best that's what it
is it's you you kind of assumed the
viewpoint you enter some kind of altered
state which is a very powerful thing but
there's a guy called Hugo Merton Berg
back in like the 1910s or something who
was already saying that cinema works
more like the mind than like objective
reality but I think I think we know
right the cinema is underperforming to
its mission yes and and part of the
reason is that we're terrifically
confused about what it's for correct and
the great ages of cinema were always
those in which the true possibilities of
cinema were foremost in producers and
directors minds and that's why you know
France produced a Golden Age of cinema
it no longer can because it's now
confused about what it's doing right
Russia produced a Golden Age of cinema
you know whenever and the same is true
by the way of painting or any other art
form it's not the technical skill that
distinguishes an art form and when you
get Rene sauces yeah it's not it's not
that suddenly there were lots of
geniuses at a technical level no no it's
the people knew what the art was for it
that's what I mean it's a slightly
strange theory but that's ultimately
what creates so-called geniuses in art
the reason why you know the France
France hasn't produced a single painter
of note in the last 150 years whereas
previous to that it produced something
like 300 painters of note this wasn't
some genetic distribution of genius and
this was to do with the fact that we
we're now not sure what we want to get
out of painting so this is where
intellectuals have a heavy role to play
that we should be helping these guys
because there's lots and lots of
technically talented people they don't
know what they're supposed to be doing
us so we need to set the agenda
thinkers need to set the agenda for
creatives and if you leave it up to
creative most creatives unfortunately
are not so good at thinking there's and
in the great ages of art it was actually
other people who would do the thinking
for the artists and would help them
along so there's just sublime I feel
like it's so it's so wonderful to hear
you speak because you've clearly thought
this through and and your soul on it
well I hope I hope that you continue to
kind of continue to scale but just you
know this is why we need collaboration
yeah let's collaborate let's collaborate
we need to come and we need we need the
people who were gonna watch this and
listen to this yes to come and join us
yes and collaborate with us yeah we
don't know where this is gonna go but it
might go to 200,000 people around the
world and somewhere people will be going
you know what I want to help on this you
know let's build some things that will
replace churches let's build some things
some community centers that will
actually bring communities together in a
new way let's make you know something
that can replace a monastery and bring
the highest ideals of you know love
together in an institution you know we
need all of this and or indeed how let's
reinvent cinema yeah ya know for sure I
mean another example is is is theater
you know at its best I remember watching
the 20th anniversary or a 25th
anniversary concert of limb is and it
was recorded and you know all the actors
they didn't they just they they all
performed the songs they had like
multiple choirs behind them it was
ecstatic and and the very end the
crescendo song that ends the play was
like literally God even for the
non-believer right like but it was like
okay I don't really believe in God but
that's God and they would film the
audience and everybody's crying
everybody's just ecstatically weeping at
just a sort of beauty beyond measure
which is the combined talents of so many
gifted brilliant singers and musicians
and directors and stage designers all
coming together to create something that
exceeds its materials literally
something that is transcendent
go back to Amin the inspiration I wanted
to talk to you is this has been
something that for me has felt like my
North Star since I was a little kid I
didn't know what the hell I wanted to do
I studied philosophy and film because
movies were at least more reliably than
other forms of art capable of evoking
that feeling no sort of ecstatic
aesthetic radiance you know and then
philosophy for like you just a love of
contending with what does this mean you
know what I mean and bringing it to life
and so wow I just it's I don't even know
what to say I'm just enough but but
before we wrap up I want to pivot a
little bit because we've been going
sacred I want to go to profane again
let's talk about the Madonna [ __ ]
complex because you know let me tell you
why this is such a big switch because
this is the human condition we started
off talking about pooping and how we
can't just fathom that human beings have
to poop and then we went and spent an
hour talking about the stuff that
clearly means a lot to us but why is it
that Freud said you can't love what you
desire and you can't desire what you
love and how come feelings of tenderness
and rapture and aesthetic ecstasy and
the people we want to hold and just love
forever we sometimes can't sexually
devour the ways in which we fantasize
about when we're alone mm-hmm look I
mean I think you know Freud's great
insight is that we learn about
tenderness around people who we cannot
have sex with in other words there is
within families within functioning
families a taboo around sexuality so our
earliest experience of love is is people
who love us deeply make us feel amazing
but will not in any way stimulator
sexually and that's the way it should be
and that sets up a conundrum for adult
life because suddenly when we emerge as
adults we're supposed to do two
relatively different things a gain
sexual fulfillment from somebody and B
bring to them all the resources of love
and tenderness and loyalty etc to bear
and you know as generations upon
generations have discovered there is
that tends to be an incompatibility now
what do we do without a compatibility
right I think like men
things we've been talking about accepted
and not berate ourselves for it you know
to see that this is not some personal
failing you know my argument with say
the kind of American marriage therapy
industry is that it seems to pathologize
this division it seems to suggest that
there is something fundamentally wrong
it's not wrong it's just desperately
inconvenient but it's very natural right
and so and the goal isn't to you know
light candles and and and you know go to
hotels etcetera that may help a little
bit of course try that as you may but to
accept the kind of tragedy of and the
complexity of being human that not all
good things belong within one setting
and maybe the bourgeois marriage with
its ideal that we can have our best
friend
our you know ideal bureaucrat co-parent
sexual partner etcetera and that this
can be one person not just for a little
while but forever this is both amazingly
beautiful and in nineteen nine or okay
at least eighty nine percent of cases
not realistic and so rather than
constantly feeling why am i abnormal we
should start have the courage to say why
have we trapped ourselves within a
definition of normality which is left
out so much of our reality and
complexity rather than beating ourselves
up why don't we just admit there is
nothing wrong with you know if you've
been married to the same person for
thirty years and you don't feel a
burning desperate desire you know to
make love to them go back to the ancient
Greeks they had five or even six
depending on how you define it words for
love right so they knew that there was
eros and the eros meant the love that
you feel very intensely the beginning of
a relationship it's highly sexual you
want to take off that clothes you want
to explore that you know the the heels
of their feet
you wanna you want to possess every part
of them and then over time that may give
way to a gap a which is a more tender
more sibling like a kind of friendship
and you know they were wise they
understood that that's what happens to
everybody and it's unfortunate that our
word love is so restrictive and put so
many of the emotions that we feel
outside of our
kind of you know ordinary consciousness
mm-hmm yeah I thought you were gonna say
there's no answer yeah yeah but yeah
there's no easy answer why are you
wrestling with this in life in your life
well you know that's that's yeah I have
I have for sure because because so much
of what I value is what we've spent the
entire hour of this podcast speaking
about embracing Butte and beauty and
truth and radiance and aesthetics in
sense-making in storytelling and in
losing myself in art I mean that's sort
of I live for that but but I also I have
have a sex drive and some sometimes what
what what I sort of desire in a carnal
fashion is something that even among you
know women that I've been in love with I
I sort of feel the kind of embarrassment
about do you know what I mean and and I
know it's it's not rational and it all
should be fine or even or even sometimes
just what I what I don't desire you know
but I think you know so it's at the
beginning of great art and great
conversation and great friendship is to
be able to go there yeah and not to
pathologize yourself yeah what you've
just outlined there is you know millions
of people out there will relate to that
this is part of the story of being human
that we're still gathering the courage
to tell ourselves and to tell our
partners as yours with love we don't
have the word still we don't have the
yeah the confidence just say is this
some curse that I was born with we you
know is this some is there something you
know so wrong with me as a general rule
when you feel I must be the only one
with this thing I really have a person
who's just statistically this cannot be
true you are probably mainlining on the
truth of millions of people at precisely
that moment how can there still be a
silence around this given the Internet
given art given though we're still at
the dawn of fully understanding what it
means to be human it I know that sounds
weird because we're supposed to be at
the end of history we're not we're still
getting going as human beings and I
think we're only beginning still to
understand our sexuality and the
psychology of love it's
at just beginning and that there's maybe
parts of ourselves that are just wired
that way and perhaps can't be changed
because you know it's like there's so
many sort of self-help like take this
four day course and embodied sacred
sexuality and it'll cure all your all
your ills you know and people say yeah
this changed my life and we found you
know and I'm a little bit like snake oil
to the Senecas often holy water to the
eager you know like so much of that is
placebo and expectation this and that
but I yeah it's like certain things feel
like have solutions and certain things I
worry have no solution but I think you
know when we say no solutions there are
always I mean death has no solution but
but we have ways as we were talking of
kind of consoling ourselves and
reconciling ourselves so yes there are
there are serious incompatibilities
within love and desire and the bourgeois
marriage is not the solution for anyone
some people manage to keep it going
some people manage to you know live with
its stresses and strains but I would
wish for them to be honest with
themselves and their partners about what
those strains are and that was also the
beginning of a of a wonderful kind of
intimacy I mean I know a couple have
been married for years and they will
honestly admit to each other the
longings and the sacrifices that they've
made to be together and it's beautiful
to see them because you see that these
are people who are getting a friendship
around some of the tragedies that their
relationship has entail and you could
say that's not very romantic but yes it
is
just say to admit it to admit to it say
to a partner I love you but you kind of
ruined my life and they can go you know
I love you too but [ __ ] you cuz in a way
you have to that's romantic in a weird
way yeah that is that is a kind of
really deep and dark intimacy oh good it
reminds me of a scene from a before
sunset or before midnight latest great
oh I [ __ ] up my whole life because of
the way you like playing the guitar
that's what I'm not going back I'm
divorcing my wife I'm staying here with
you and it's funny maybe we can end on
on that trilogy as we wrap our
conversations because the first film is
as this opens up a space in which I
thought
I wanted to live in forever the first
film is the feeling of meeting somebody
they take your breath away you get off
the train in the city neither of you
know so you're in a mythopoetic altered
state of consciousness together and the
night feels like it's outside of time
and everything about it is I could fall
in love inside this moment I want to
live inside this pop song I want to see
beautiful art with you and explore the
insides of your soul and then the end of
that movie is the ultimate in
bittersweet because it's dawn and then
he recites the WH Auden poem to her and
all the clocks in the city began to were
and chime or let not time deceive you
you cannot conquer time headaches and
and worries vaguely Life leaks away and
time will have its fancy tomorrow or
today and then they're walking around an
alley and somebody's playing a harp in
the apartment and he stops and they
danced to the harpsichord and then he
stops her and she just looks so
beautiful like she's just this she's a
woman in love and he pauses her and he
goes and he fakes like a fake carries I
want to take a picture of you and all
this so I never forget you and I never
forget this and that moment is so
heartbreaking and I feel like I've been
in rebellion my entire life against
accepting that that moment will pass and
I think that it doesn't have to pass
with but you can keep that moment going
in your life you can keep having those
experiences it's a choice you know there
are costs to that kind of life you may
at certain points feel lonely feel
without a home without a half without
the fire you know
and we're also creatures that like a
fire that like our home for sure
and you may feel the absence of that so
you have the adventure you know you're
Ulysses out there in the high seas but
you'll you know you're longing for
Ithaca rhetoric and at the same time you
know what is the alternative to just
stay in Ithaca and that can be dull -
because it's day after day it's the
routine so whatever choice you make they
will be suffering and longing in one
direction or another there will be
something incomplete that helps a lot to
know that the incompleteness is endemic
to the human animal in the same way that
we have parts to our brains we have
parts to our ambition
and they don't all pull in one direction
there is no path that reconciles all our
longings you know and so you don't
believe in rollin bar it's notion of
moments in which all of my desires are
abolished in the plenitude of their
satisfaction no I believe in moments but
I don't believe in years I don't believe
in decades a hundred percent believe in
moment okay but we don't live in moments
we live in decades what I've been trying
to live in mom right that's my that's my
curse in my blessing that's my life
that's why I that's what I'm sometimes
lonely and I don't have a fixed because
I'm and and we're interested in your
experiment you know we'll see how see
what houses and and and I think your
temperament it makes you ideally suited
to that and and and you may be one of
the you know you are a rare individual
in that case and and keep that going on
and you know anyway it's so funny we
started off talking about incompleteness
and we're ending talking about
incompleteness so alone table tone thank
you you are one of my heroes I'm happy
you exist I take great refuge in your
writing just thank you thank you thank
you thank you well thank you you're an
incredibly positive force in the
universe it's been a great joy thank you
thanks